you've given away like more than forty
million dollar like this is some where
does that come from in you good luck
right I've been incredibly lucky I you
know a little bit of guilt a little bit
of shame no I I've been it's I think
it's my mom is incredibly generous soul
and I think I've been lucky enough to be
surrounded by really generous people and
and so it you know it feels like I
already have too much and so it's it's
such an opportunity to feel better is to
give something away I'd always try and
give money to people that are have their
hands out or a little cardboard sign or
whatever because I think that could be
sitting right there no problem if I
wasn't so lucky
um and and then the echo in my mind is
that sort of the people you know they're
just gonna spend that on booze and I
think so
well that's what I would probably spend
it on you know go get a beer or go in a
sandwich oh good go get a sandwich and a
beer but it's not up to me but that
temporary solution is fine while we try
and figure out a more sustainable
solution I will buy that personal beer
because I can afford to buy them a beer
and then I would go and try and figure
out a way to make it so that they don't
have to sit on the street in with dirty
socks on if they don't want to and I
think about the injustice of people
being judged by their names or judged by
the color of their skin or by their
religion or by their past or by their
language
and I think all those things that that's
that stop people from fulfilling their
potential damaged us all so if you have
to live in a place that's around the
corner down and hidden because your
parents can't afford a better place to
live a place if you have to get if
there's not a bus stop that goes to your
neighborhood but it goes near your
neighborhood then you have to cross over
a thing and take on a hobo trail down to
your house you can't grow up and feel
like you're part of it and then we lose
you or we could lose you you know and
because we are giving you less of a
chance we're that's we're taking your
your opportunities away that's how I
think about it so what if we give
everybody more of a chance then our view
there's a greater possibility for the
future if we get everybody thinking
about the future our future we have a
better chance of surviving it if we
don't we are doomed